um oh yeah
you i remember getting it i said mike
ready again today
yeah you ever like stepped into it hey
get the [ __ ] don't touch my personage
i'm wondering
i'm wearing your favorite i mean too
colorful for you but you still you like
are those golden gooses yeah oh damn
those are those golden goose
these are golden goose wow yeah they
make those those are big
brothers italian i think they're made by
husband and wife uh the the french
they're they're talent is that right the
friend you sure
positive because i bought a pair in
france and they were a lot cheaper so
maybe that's why yeah look up are you
sure you would know
i think it's a time but maybe i'm wrong
um i like how you and i like how you got
this on
right yeah i got i just let it out a
little bit let it out a little about
baby feet so
you don't want to get too crazy just
have a baby v you you show off the chest
a little bit
i do but i i'm a little i feel a little
bad about myself today
um just today well
we're talking hold on we're talking now
hold on we're talking man i don't like
the way you said that
all right trying to fix that now let's
not keep swinging my face
yeah yeah mine too yeah but
go ahead brian as you were hey how was
on ontario you [ __ ] it was amazing
how was that drive though was it you
know what it was an hour the longest it
took me was an hour and 40. it was
thursday
friday friday yeah that friday will get
you it'll get you but usually it takes
longer than that i'll take the one for
you i know
i know people are going to send a stat
you know has the worst traffic i've ever
been in
and i've been in la over 10 years now
wait the whole seattle
oh that's bad is that right uh you know
we were there with buster because buster
lives out there yeah and i'm like buster
why
because we want to go 20 miles because
we're in tacoma it's like 20 25 miles
tacoma
to downtown seattle we're going down
there to you know hang out i looked down
like oh 20 miles let's take a sweat
maybe 30 minutes max
bro two hours two hours and buster was
saying it was time so many people moved
there and they didn't have time to
build the infrastructure well they can't
because they cross water so a lot is
crossing bodies of water so it's two
lanes yep so it goes two lanes
five so unless you got a ferry
[ __ ] hilarious the traffic was bad
it's because the it
moved out there right or something or
what's what's out there that there's a
ton
i'll tell you i'll tell you boeing's out
there yeah i mean it's it's it's it's
leaving there yeah but they're there
it's like everybody moved
no state tax no state tax you know about
that
i i saw you light up cat have you been
in seattle
uh i have not oh it's from no state i do
like the
cold shore wow yeah
here's the thing though if you're gonna
move there let me the house don't have
ac
because it doesn't get that well i think
maybe the newer ones are always damp and
cold
and it rains so they don't load so like
we got this airbnb
clearly haunted i had to sleep on the
couch but yeah that [ __ ] was haunted
i was 100 years old oh and i meant to
send this to you and
tripoli and eddie bravo they had a huge
family
uh tree yeah of the ross childs
interesting very it's like on a mantle
yeah
like you might have been in one of the
houses of the illuminati yeah
it was illuminati uh prices but the
thing is they have they see so daddy
slept on his underwear on the couch
because it was so hot
because well the hashtag good guy here
hashtag a good guy
hashtag know their headliner do this in
the world yeah i slept on the couch
because daddy gets the master right
there he's paying for it
i guess master yeah that is big right
now can we call it masters i feel like
that's a little
uh we're not going to let them dictate
how we speak okay
i don't know who the [ __ ] keeps changing
the rules and these line all the lines
you can't call them
where are they in a room
but these are the same people that are
good like speech is violence and they go
wait oh listen no
it's a master it's a mess the master
bedroom stop everybody
it's not designed all right say it again
master bedroom
i want now for some reason yeah
master bedroom see it's too much see
well you say it though i did feel a
little racist when i say it doesn't do i
stay in the master bedroom
anyway so uh i'm always in the master
bedroom but then a little val kilmer
stash over there
caught himself a little creamy fly in
his web
you got yourself cream and fly in your
webs
he was like oh i connected this girl on
tinder or the short kings only.com or
whatever
shortcut uh he goes she's coming to the
show man i said all right kyle well i'll
do this for you
if you somehow convince this girl to
come back to the crib you can have the
mask the best of the master
and daddy asleep on the couch you're a
good man that's what happened that's
that's what you call
a benevolent daddy a good friend better
boss
i was working well yeah he asked if he
had to ask if he could clock out
it was a word it is i'm impressed well
you know i did notice
i do find it curious that i i was gone
for a little bit you hired some peeps
and everyone is much shorter than you
are
and and that's okay but i oh two there
well i i have some extra shoes i said
what size do you guys take and they were
like
six or whatever six i thought everybody
is
you know what no but i'm like you to get
the job let me finish
you don't have to be a large man hold on
i was gonna say i went
i went you you got that's true because i
would hire nothing but big muscular guys
which i want to get to in a second
i'll get to that but i i just thought to
myself
everybody is i mean you're towering over
everyone
in your no studios no mark harley's
normal yeah i know but it's just these
two
your employees cat everybody and i was
like maybe you like to
lord over there no hey jin's the biggest
korean in the world yeah
you know what you are
oh what would you have done b thursday
night show
yeah when first night yeah that show
hanging out hanging out
jay's thick ass comes around the room
run
run he's gathering everybody up like
captain america
there's a guy with a knife or gun out
there he's trying to get in here and
we're like what the [ __ ] he's got a
knife
and we're like what so then big david
lucas he opens the door he's like where
he's at and jay said shut the [ __ ]
door
justin the smaller guy is like what are
we looking at
beer bottle glass everywhere blood
cuts just on the head what right yes so
we all go this way
now kyle's supposed to be filming it
that's why i have him on the road but
kyle went i want to live
you know all his camera equipment and
ran out okay
smart so then jay goes we got to go this
way well
it was the only door to the stage i
didn't realize that yeah and it was
locked from the outside or
maybe i just can't figure out the lock
right and then ship everyone's on me
like this
like we're running the cap oh i was i
was i was like that cop
i was like no and i hear chappelle go
i'm too young to die
yeah and i went all right we're not
going to die and then a knife
the threat of a knife or a gun the gun
is not scary
but i thought all right we got to get
out of here because this guy's [ __ ]
coming i don't get stabbed
so then when you wonder why dead left
600 bench 4 25 whatever
this is why daddy shattered that door
shattered did he die it was so funny
ran through it oh i went back up to the
palace i went no
no just give me a second you didn't kick
you just you just
no shoulder shoulders straight up
shoulders
and that kind of size the door shatters
on the side right but here's the thing
it goes
into the crowd yeah it went straight
here i go oh my god and i go oh
everyone's like yeah i'm like no
no
so then they're like what's the matter i
was like there's a guy with a knife or a
gun
but don't be be cool he's back there
everybody's good and was like what the
heck
let me start walking through the crowd
holy [ __ ] i ain't not here we didn't
even realize it went to the stage
i had no idea what it was you feel like
you got to create in that situation if
you run you might be dead
you might want to sit tight stay low
love feels good but you let him come in
and then you you just grab the barrel
and you do a krav maga
homie was shredded the homeless man was
shredded he was shredded
and he's on meth and that's a hard
that's a lot that's tough probably
fights because someone outside because
we just had pulled
up some one of the audience members was
messing with him because he was like
he was being like when they were kind of
just out there you kind of just like
ignore him and then kind of walk away
well
this dude thought he could just like
talk to him be like yo man stop tripping
it's like yo this dude's out of his mind
completely and then
what what set the dude off is the the
homeless man had a beer
and the dude took his beer yeah and
that's what set him off yeah
and then oh that's why freaking [ __ ]
out yeah so he's like man get my [ __ ]
beer back get my beer back
and then finally dude like puts it down
or you know like tries to like walk away
nor but the dude was he was just you
seen big j that's when
he was like get out of here no he didn't
say brendon he said he said my lord
he was like he said lord brendan save
the law
then the cheerleader came out of his
chapel he's like give me an a
i don't want to die chappelle you got to
get
you got to get low and bear down and be
right yeah
that's what i said dude come on dude
first of all david lucas
350 pounds we have 250 yeah we got the
one phase two for like we should have
been
and the one ton club has to form a
vector and be ready to absorb
come what may you don't know what set it
off was jay
jay jay was the one that likes james
everybody
oh [ __ ] and i go where he goes who gives
a [ __ ] get out
he's like it's either a gun or not scare
me that's why i was like
i don't want to die either so i don't
know if you i told you this story but in
my home in venice
a gentleman decided to set up not just a
tent
but an entire sort of encampment uh just
right here on the
adjoining corner right there and i went
and the whole
the whole and then he's in this woman's
backyard and he's just kind of crazy
and i go i go and i go over and i go you
can't do this and he goes nah i can't
i'm doing it i live here
so under my rights and i go well no
you're not you're gonna move this and
then he goes
no and i go well you're gonna i'm just
telling you you're gonna yeah so i get
confrontational with the crazy man it's
like oh that now
now now here's the thing you think he's
not a small guy and he's in his
and he's in very loose tidy white hell
yeah and he gets
out of his tent and now stands there and
begins to
sort of try to fight me where he's
raising his you know
face but he's doing this and he's kind
of and i go and i'm and i'm standing
there and i'm like this guy's
he's crazy i'm gonna have my hand have
whether he can fight or not i don't have
my hands full oh
and also he's super dirty and also i
don't want to get bit and also a
thousand reasons don't do you think
it's gonna make you sick what do you get
whatever my neighbor comes over who's
very hippy dippy
and he goes um whoa whoa whoa whoa hey
it's okay and he asks
the guys his name and stuff like that
and i kind of kind of skedaddle
but it was about a daddy ran off two
minutes
two minute thing where i'm standing in
my ground and then daddy ran off he said
skedaddle
yeah daddy ran off daddy didn't
skedaddle right rude no
do you want better but they're gone
though because now i looked i saw on the
news
this is clean yeah i'll tell you why so
i i decide
i decide you're right i go i should have
run immediately but instead i'm standing
my ground like an idiot and then i walk
off
well guess what ran off when they took
down his tent you know what they found
in his tent
knife guns true machetes yeah two
machetes
he's on the street bro he's on the
street and he has machetes
every day is the purge for him yeah and
i don't have much defense against a
machete
so don't fight guys like that they're
they're just crazy
and that's what jay said jason of course
you can beat that gap but if he's on
meth and has
and oh that's why he found out he didn't
have a knife he had like a
spear that he forged into yeah it was
like it was like it's like a big like a
stick that's a problem it was a stick
13 to 2 i think voted to have there are
no uh in 30 days
garcetti has to sign and it looks like
he's going to no uh encampments no tents
no loitering even under underpasses or
on the sidewalks in los angeles make it
illegal yeah and
venice they're cleaning all of l.a
though right all of you everything
is really nice huh oh dude they're cool
daddy should be able to sell his place
now
we'll see we'll see who ran it at least
but that news
it dried up right quick once they ran
two articles
well one once uh that uh sheriff came
out they were like hell no
this ain't happening oh yeah he just
went you're not that's not your
jurisdiction you have to get to know
your unhoused neighbors he was like cool
great story everybody now you cannot
refuse help if it's offered
so it used to be aren't they just going
to lock them up now though and then
they're going to be out in the street
newsom has initiated a 12 billion dollar
bond
to raise uh services for the homeless
the problem is then you get developers
who are like i'll build housing and then
they make money
oh god now now um
none of this matters really because i
don't know if you've seen have you
watched this new tv show
god it better not be something stupid f
boy island what no i can't i don't like
the name i thought it's on hbo
said [ __ ] boy island does it trigger you
a little bit no because i saw
because when i go to watch game of
thrones on hbo app yeah i saw [ __ ] boy
island and game of thrones
yeah and i went oh i'm not a 22 year old
man so i'm gonna watch game of thrones
but you watch [ __ ] boy island i i i is
it like a joke
is it a joke show in the past 10 minutes
it's it makes no sense the show but i
have to say that nicki
minaj is the host then i might watch the
dudes make me feel bad about myself
why well i've never these shows all the
guys
but have you seen season six of uh yes i
have
now can i just say something my fury's
on there when you see
i understand i got you on that i got you
when you see these guys
you you say to yourself what nfl
football team
did you step off of and and are you
playing
middle linebacker or running back i
don't see what they look like i think i
would say that but i promise you those
are the dudes
that's nothing yeah just keep going
there there are a couple of these guys
where you just go
how are you built like that well not
them though right you're not seeing them
not those guys it's those guys aren't
bad but
you got some real you've got some real
athletes on there and it's just
a little bit whatever they did they got
the most muscular guys they could find
you know what my problem with all this
brian is the show
i wish you were focused on the girls
what is my girlfriend so there's my
girlfriend my girlfriend's there there's
my favorite guy right there
that's your favorite guy yeah well that
well that's what you want to look like
i mean for me that's that's well you
kind of look like that i mean he's not
like
that he's not get some shots of that guy
he's got an instagram let's take a look
at that guy first exactly can you tell
me that and then we'll just talk
but i need to know if he's not at the
show though it makes no sense
because she had the girls that voted
they're nice guys or [ __ ] boys i i just
don't
oh that's what they got to figure out do
they meet them right away or yeah but
they i don't get it it's like
50 guys and three girls none of it makes
much sense
yeah here we go there we go here we go i
mean you know
calm
he's just stupid is that natty you don't
know right you can't tell
he might be natty he's actually huge his
legs are teeny dude
he's an addict you can't tell from these
pictures
yeah there he is what do you think
maddie maddy
what huh what do you think stuff well
there he is there he is well there we go
i mean you know that's he skips leg day
though that's the problem he might
oh man i don't know but does he well
he's running the bleachers
he he's an ex-athlete for sure something
right maybe really
i'm just gonna assume like as an athlete
well i mean how come you're not doing
all the sports i'm
doing all the sports you don't go on
[ __ ] well and if you're crushing them
you don't know dude
oh he boxes like he's a boxer no i don't
think he's a boxer
maybe he's just an ex he's a
professional exerciser i'm not mad at
his legs there
you're not mad at that body come on no
i mean see that's new culture i mean
dude you gotta commit zoo culture that's
every day
every day every day yeah and they work
out just like that no shirts on
really yeah ooh is that acne on his back
uh you know what
mm-hmm is it acne that's not acne that's
probably
slow suspect that's acne no there's some
acne either way acne or vitiligo
congratulations to him yeah either way
since the rights uh anyways
[Laughter]
you watch it for the bros you know what
hey did you hear the new stuff yeah he's
jack congrats
um did you did you
with the simone bile stuff you see more
stuff came out mm-hmm
do you hear she had a morning story more
which is what we said
but did you see uh so she had uh an
exemption for medication
for ritalin yes yeah and she's had it
forever yeah she's been taking it since
i guess serena and venus were also
taking it there's something
there's something else that she's
getting that i guess gymnasts get and
it's a case of what they call the
twisties
which is that you know that's vertigo so
a lot of people get it when they go off
ritalin so if you've been on wren for a
long time and get off of it
one of the side effects is vertigo or
loss of balance yeah really
my here's my thing with and if and
obviously you can't compete if you have
vertigo and all that [ __ ] so
but i thought so this is your favorite
but gymnasts get a sense uh when they do
a lot of
uh jumping that there's this con this
thing that's called
um you get you feel like you're lost in
the air so you can't spot
the mission you don't have that she's
the goat so she's dead that's what she
said no that's
no she they say it's from
taking berlin for so many years then
going cold turkey one of that things
that can give you vertigo
so obviously you can't do all those
[ __ ] flips in the air because that
makes difference
well i think with that and yeah god
bless her she should definitely not do
it
my thing with that is if she's been
doing really in this long
wouldn't ridlen be a form of a
performance enhancer
because it gives you focus yeah so at
that sport wouldn't that be a
performance-enhancing drug
which she has an exemption for well i
guess tokyo believes that right but a
lot of that's why they want to allow her
to do it
yeah and apparently i guess serena and
uh venus
were also on it too yeah a lot of people
i mean you know it's
it's it's standard for children uh when
so when kids have adhd or whatever it's
almost the first thing that they
they give you guanfacine which is
something that actually lowers
can it it slows you down they give it to
you at night
it it slows your heart rate down um you
know
it's more of a saturday ritalin in the
morning yeah ritalin
have you taken i don't know i don't know
i don't know it's actually adderall but
it's like time released
it's lateral yeah a time released kind
of thing is that not performance
enhancing
i i would just because you know mlb it's
illegal yet
so many guys take it so so many guys
take it i would say it definitely gets
them focused as it's help it helps me
focus if i take it it
helps me focus now yeah my own thing is
so
if again i don't know i don't know how
gymnastics works here's my other thing i
don't give a [ __ ] about gymnastics
but it's interesting to talk about but
if you can't perform without that
substance there's a problem right
and that's strange yeah and i don't know
enough about her history where she has
to take it but they had this they asked
the same question when
when uh somebody was taking beta
blockers okay and beta blockers i think
that's for the heart right
well so beta blockers apparently get you
to calm down it's a little bit like
xanax or something where you won't so if
you have an audition
this guy was a musician and he had to
audition for an orchestra and he was
nervous
yeah and he took beta blockers and they
were like is that a form of performance
enhancing drugs we get into these
questions but that's i mean it's more so
medical right yeah
it is it's a medical exemption yeah but
i mean
beta blockers might be something
different but technically you you can't
even take caffeine
before us is that right no caffeine's
illegal is that right it's a performance
you can have you you can like drink
coffee all the time
if when you solder i forget the nevada
commissioner come like do you can't have
coffee
in the workout room what a certain
amount of caffeine
of the fight right no the day and you
can never take adderall
not a shot no but this is a form of
adderall so it helps you focus and
prolongs your energy it's just different
because she's been taking it since she
was a kid
like if you're do does it show up in
tests yeah no i didn't know that
yeah yeah form a meth bell it's a it's a
it's an amphetamine salt
he's almost it's an amphetamine like if
you were applying for a job right
you guys aren't gonna do random drug
tests are you we don't do random i mean
you need to be on [ __ ] meth for a lot
of
kids
i would say i would say the way they
look at these things is they say
the child is dealing with a deficit to
begin with right
which is a whole another subject it's a
whole nother section all of a sudden now
kids have adhd
when back in the day no kids did well i
i i was i thought it was more back in
the day than it is now right now
well let me let me tell you how it works
way more let me tell you exactly how it
works with somebody who's
without going into too much detail but
like this is how it works if you have a
child who has you know issues like this
okay
um you have to be very careful because
there's an industry out there
and there is an industry that makes a
lot of money off of
your child's uh adhd and deficits okay
and what they'll do and your kid can be
nine your kid can be even younger
and what they'll do and is is you get a
bunch of professionals
who start talking to each other and the
kid might need some adhd
okay and then you might want to give him
something to calm down at night so he
can sleep but then you might want also
he might be suffering from i don't know
anxiety or something yeah well now he's
got to see a psychiatrist
and the psychiatrist well a lot of times
a lot of them and this is from a
pediatrician i know a lot of them
will go uh he should be on prozac or on
on so now you got your kid on an
antidepressant
on ritalin and on something called guam
facility and probably for life
and probably and not just probably
definitely for life
and and and so and here's the thing
they're gonna say he's on i don't mean
interrupt you i'm gonna say he's on
focus
and he's not paying attention in class
well do you think for a
second he might not be into whatever the
[ __ ] you're teaching
well that's me you're not addressing in
a way that he can comprehend it exactly
do you think maybe you
going over [ __ ] the greek history the
kid's not
into it and it's a you problem how much
exercise is the kid doing are you tiring
him out is he physically getting his
yayas out bro i put a uh
uh not a apple watch but like a fake one
for kids
trex kids tiger on thursday ran
18 000 steps
yeah that's so important and came home i
was like he's in the exhaust
you understand so you have children that
are that are not only
living on sugar they're also in front of
a screen all day and they're never doing
exercise
and then what happens is school's boring
them because it's not being taught
probably
so now your kid has a pathology and then
you if you trust the experts you've got
to question what you've got to question
but remember every expert too and we
have a lot of friends who are doctors
there's p they they get benefits from
prescribing this medication
they get bumps yes bob yes it's a whole
[ __ ]
industry so so what they're what they're
steering away from is that
each kid does not like learn like every
kid learns differently
you know i mean i mean would you say
that yes
look it's actually because like to be
able to take like i mean how many kids
are in a classroom
like there's so many there's 40 if it's
a publisher i think in 2000 i think it
was 2007 or 2000 there was
there was one gender clinic there was
one clinic that dealt with
children who were born with you know
they were intersex they were dead they
were born
both sets of genitals or whatever it is
or kids that really identify with
another sex
now there are hundreds and hundreds okay
and you have to understand in places
like washington where you just were
uh there is there are 13 year olds and
15 year olds
that can go to planned parenthood or
kaiser and without their parents consent
they can get puberty blockers and in
some cases can even get
even get uh surgery puberty like
like getting their breasts trimmed okay
you've never heard of that and so
now you have in some cases some girls in
class because
girls tend to be very socially
aggressive when they're younger and they
tend
and social contagion is something that's
very you know catchy
you know your friends think one way and
you're going to go along with that and
we're social animals but girls there's a
lot of pressure for that boys deal with
it a little bit differently
i'm just generalizing what's interesting
is that in some
according to some surveys some girls are
essentially
thirty percent of the class identifies
as trans
and that's not what they are they're
just going through a confusing time in
their life but you have an industry
now and an ideological agenda that will
jump in right away and say you need you
know let's let's get you over
this way let's cut it off they're
capitalizing on it well yeah
instead of allowing a child whose brain
is not developed to go through whatever
they're going through
let them go through it let them be
eighteen or twenty or twenty one
let them develop and make their own i
completely agree
the problem is the exception like i
forget the guy who's on rogan who deals
with this he's talking about this
he said the problem is sometimes there
are ten-year-olds who legitimately
they should be able to do what they want
my problem is if if i was growing up in
this time listen
i loved robocop i love robert i wanted
to be
a half robot yes and if my dad was like
yeah sure dude cut your [ __ ] arms off
and
put mechanical arms on it and i'd be
sitting here with two mechanical arms
hating my [ __ ] what you're saying is
that
it's because i was 12. yes i was
confused
and i wanted robot arms yes my dad
wouldn't allow me your prefrontal cortex
is not developed enough to make it i was
12. to make life
decisions right you know you can't make
decisions
sound decisions are going to affect the
rest of your life no yeah that's why
they're children
and that's why you you have to allow a
child to develop into an adult to make
those decisions
so yeah you don't necessarily think
every kid is out there that is adhd
that i don't i that's why i want to be
channel i'm saying yeah
and if the scientist and doctor i would
be sitting here in a helmet
and have abs like that right how many
robocops i remember i watched three back
in the
early 90s and then one more new one is
yeah complete trash
i wanted to be a cowboy i wanted to live
on a horse and
on a ranch yeah we could do that dude i
know right
i wanted roblox arms dude you gotta
remove your arms
can you imagine what that was like yeah
let's take his arms off it's his body
his choice being it'll take his [ __ ]
arms off yeah
that's one of the greatest beginnings of
a movie remember remember that
so violent my dad made me close my eyes
i'd always go like this when the
computer malfunctions every time i feel
like the computer malfunctions and when
they shoot him yeah they just all get
their guns out
there's 20 guys shooting the guy well in
the beginning where they're running
there it is b that's what you wanted i
love the music too
you're one of them remember the music
dude orion made it
orion oh ryan yeah yeah that's [ __ ]
great
yeah my dad wanted me to be a robot god
bless him i'm grateful for it today
hey uh brian i saw a little video clip
on your
ig the crowd went well for the
the man dragging dude they were just
shouting it
and i'm resisting it they wanted it
and just speaking and the way you did it
like ow i saw fire i don't know if you
could really see it in this video but i
thought it's like they're screaming for
it yeah
oh can't guys i can't what are you gonna
do with all these people screaming for
it i can't
i see i don't hear anybody saying man
dragon they said you were you just did
it look at that
look at that that was the most exciting
thing that's what was exciting
by the way ever since you were like so
excited every time i drive around
people in
hey and i just i couldn't help it i just
went
down they freaked out it's so fun now
it's like all right
this is the best looking don't don't
[ __ ] don't say it doesn't exist
because then people are like yeah
yeah you know like yeah we want yeah
don't deny the best way to
like have a nickname is to call you
something have everybody say it's never
gonna catch on and people are like
oh yeah [ __ ] you i'll tell you how about
the racist guy
in uh tacoma david oh
for david lucas i heard he dropped the n
word with a with a hard r
the heart the hardest proud boy from the
back of the room
yeah getting the care you need to stay
healthy shouldn't be hard man or
expensive everyone should be able to
afford their medications check out
goodrx they help me find the lowest
price
on my prescriptions every freaking time
with goodrx you can instantly compare
prices for your prescription
at every pharmacy in your neighborhood
and save up to eighty percent
that's eighty percent eight zero
good rx is free and easy to use many
times it's often cheaper than user
insurance copay or medicare
with goodrx you can find discounts for
your prescriptions at over
70 000 pharmacies like cvs kroger
walgreens rite aid vaughn's walmart and
so much more
good rx is the number one most
downloaded medical app
and millions of americans use goodrx to
get affordable health care every month
start saving up to eighty percent that's
eighty percent on your prescription
today
go to goodrx.com fighter that is good
rx.com
fighter goodrx.com fighter goodrx is not
insurance but can be used instead of
insurance in 2020 goodrx users receive
an average savings of 70
off retail prices what's up guys ufc 265
is here and we're doing a fight
campaigning this saturday
7 p.m live on youtube and
twitch so you can get it at both spots
but if you want to watch
fights and make bank bro do it with
draftking sports book the official
sports betting partner
of the ufc and they have a heavyweight
offer for you guys this weekend all
right
they have special odds boosts for all
you guys
all right so for this week uh all you
gotta do is head to the app
find the brendan shops picks b shops
picks under the odds boost tab
doesn't matter if you're a new or
existing customer you bet on my two
fighters get your boosted odds and ride
along with your thick friend
and i picked freaking derrick lewis and
michael chiesa
to win to get it done two dogs and you
boost the odds
all right all new users download the top
rated draftking sportsbook app now use
the promo code
fighter when you sign up bet on my
parliament fighters derek lewis and
michael kiesa
to win saturday night for ufc 265 take
advantage of your boys special odds
boost
that's promo code fighter only at
draftking sportsbook the official sports
betting partner of the ufc
must be 21 and older new jersey
pennsylvania indiana michigan or
virginia only restrictions apply
see draftkings.com sportsbook for
details gambling problem call wayne
hunter gambler
or an indiana 1-809 with it or in
virginia 888-532-3500
how about the racist guy in uh tacoma
david oh for david lucas i heard he
dropped the n-word with a with a hard r
the heart the hardest proud boy from the
back of the room
yeah because i want you i watch a show
from the back room where no one can see
me i just want to see how the show's
going from a fan
standpoint so i watch everybody set in
the back yeah i'm sitting there and this
guy's like
disgruntled and he's i guess they were
he was giving him [ __ ] before he even
walked in they're like this guy's gonna
be a problem
and then the guy's wife said something
you know david's uh
[ __ ] roaster so he's like wait hold
up what does [ __ ] say
and then she said somebody goes no han
what'd you say because then he'll just
like
call him yeah well guys yeah what does
that mean yeah
yeah this guy wasn't having it no so
then he was like you know what you're
saying someone around me tell me what
she said so he just wants what she says
we can riffle on it
and that he they just shut down he goes
on about a set
and i see this guy in the back he's like
i came here for one reason
one reason only he said we didn't come
here for this
he's like that comic is [ __ ] he said
that fat ass i didn't say that
said that fat ass is racist which
doesn't make any sense david
yeah he's insane he's a black
conservative
he's a black conservative he's okay he's
the best
is david live in l.a yeah yeah okay here
in texas
yeah he makes no he's a black
conservative it's so funny it's [ __ ]
hilarious
he goes am i the only one in here sad
that trump's not present anymore
yeah that's one of his jokes is that
it's a super
uh liberal place where you were to come
here yeah but then the yeah then the
guys they're like all right so you guys
so he says he's racist yeah he's like
racist and
and the wife is like yeah we want our
[ __ ] money back in the match like
sure just
get out the [ __ ] door and then david
goes all right that's my time
and he goes that is your time hard all
and you just call him a racist and now
he calls him up
wow that's a confused guy oh my god
yeah it was weird so intense we went to
a place called
the glory honey hole honey hole they
wouldn't they went to the gate
they went to the honey they went to the
honey hole man i almost said loyal
wish it was a glory hole you've heard i
never
heard it called a honeycomb why haven't
i put those two words together honey
holes
yeah what is the honey hole the best
honey kyle you had the sandwich the best
sandwich in seattle oh to a tough it's a
sandwich
yeah no bar it's next to a it's it's in
the gay district but right the sands are
so good on you
but you like that name though the name
is hilarious honey honey hole
the best sandwiches in seattle like uh
what just [ __ ] ah how would you
describe it it's like on a really good
sourdough
oh provolone and onions it's pretty
famous in seattle yeah
it's called honey hole for god's sakes
honey you go next door and get strapped
on what the [ __ ] you want yeah
that went across street got some straw
lights
did you bring a souvenir home no i
wanted to
you know that like the the was it the
chat remember that
chat chat district that they took over
and like locked down
yeah and on the news you think it's like
seattle's like this war zone
it's all gone it's all nothing there
yeah it's all white
this is all the media stuff and my dad
was just in san francisco and i was like
dad
it's like i heard it's terrible up there
is it like is it just chaos he's like
what
no i said fisherman's wharf i was like i
walked all over the no it's fine
yeah i was like it's not all the way
that's the problem with and i was like
what about mass he's like no
no you gotta you don't have seattle no
no no
yeah yeah none really la's the only
place
wow yeah no mass no mess really yeah
cause i yeah once because yeah even
though we went
to the outstore outdoor starbucks i
wanted that walgreens and yeah no
no well you know ontario you go 50 miles
outside of la
yeah yeah yeah they're not working it is
it's a completely different story
it's america it's just here it's america
and they're they're just like uh they
they work for a living how about that
you know they're just too busy yeah but
you know the rest of us are just uh
jim what'd you do this weekend the boys
were talking about your instagram
stories your feet on the road
you were literally i was making a joke i
was at a like a
an 80s tribute band thing with my girl
in orange county
so i just kept saying i'm at the concert
at the baby it's it's like so obvious
it's not the baby
i thought it actually was like little
kids who's your who's your favorite 80s
band is there an 80s band that kind of
blows you away
or stands just tested you always catch
me on these bruh no it's okay i'm not
gonna think i'm trying to think of who
in the 80s why do you think on that
director you would have loved the museum
uh the baby's like losing a bunch of
[ __ ] now because those homeowners we
have current events on him too yeah
yeah he got kicked off like an hour
before
why wait an hour before but tell him
before he gets on the [ __ ] plane
but i feel like he's i feel like the
baby
i hate when you say the baby the baby
i feel like you said the baby and master
bedroom but i'm on this
street on the street yeah i i read those
comments but i feel like he was trying
to
tell people to practice safe sex in a
really clumsy way i don't know
but he was because he was saying stuff
about a lot of things it wasn't just
that the problem is nowadays he doubled
right he doubled down
nowadays they can just come after
everything you do like you get kicked
off lollapalooza
if paypal paypal is working with the uh
defamation league to
to basically like if you have
if you're part of a quote-unquote hate
group they decide what that is
so if you're kind of a part of a
right-wing political action committee or
whatever if you're a band
or something you can't you know yeah you
can't use paypal
so these neutral providers the way
people used to say that again
but don't use paypal then well but there
are a lot of times it's it's
cost effective right you're running a
business yeah it's hard to it's hard to
not use it i just think that's
outrageous because
they are using their political agenda
and ideology to stop people from using
their
their
you know services it's a problem so
they're just assuming these yeah
when you start defining what that is you
got to prove well when you have a board
of four
white people who decide what you can and
can't be said it's like facebook and
youtube it's dicey yeah it's dicey man
super big issue chin you would have
loved the museum uh jay buster and i
went to the music uh
uh it's got like the grunge exhibit quit
touching each other uh
but it had all like cobain's sad novel
entries
no it didn't we don't have all that oh
it's called
you went to uh you do you go to a music
museum is it yeah museum pop culture i
can't was that
hey listen you know yeah yeah yeah yeah
this guy
in a million million years most of y'all
eat a dick
million years ago came back was like
dude that jimmy hendrix
guitar and had a piece of hair on him
like yeah this guy who put it in there
no i
know i get a call from my father my own
father i roasted my father who i
love and respect he i go where are you
guys i'm in i'm in the museum of musical
instruments
huh i was like i kept for a week
did they have the exhibit on didgeridoos
and guitars
how many strings in a basement but jay
said jay's like dude you should have
went just to see how much chappelle
knows about music he was like it was
insane they would show like
a nirvana t-shirt and he could say the
city
the day
and i said jay i know exactly what
concert he wore that it was 1992
wow festival and i go to youtube wow and
i would show jay
where exactly his knowledge is insane
and i said chappelle that's your pot
because we're doing here on the thick
boy network we're doing
a podcast he he has such an extensive
knowledge of music yeah your podcast can
be on music yeah sure
i'm rebranding it we were branding it
and and you'll see what it is because
then
people yeah i won't say what it is you
can interview people who
in them well he has all the connections
all these bands and [ __ ]
between me and him we have all these
connections yeah him on the show he
could dive into his favorite band like
every week
bands you never heard of i think it's
good no one's doing it i don't know how
i
don't know how i have this insane
knowledge for what do you think about
what you like
yeah well it goes back to that learning
[ __ ] when i was a kid
that was the thing that i that i paid
attention to
the most in school if they were like
they're like oh no you got adhd
yeah but think if the teacher would like
turn me like oh you like nirvana and
then
they taught you gave you books about
nirvana like you'd be stoked true yeah
do you know what i had to come to the
realization shut up
how about that okay you didn't even give
him a chance
that wasn't gay you know what but you
know what i thought about
i think about the fact that um i every
time i was on a set
as an actor and i came to la to be an
actor yeah
i always was waiting for it to be over
but i never admitted that myself but you
know what i was doing on set
i was making everybody laugh so for me
the only thing i wanted to do was make
people laugh around me
which means i'm a [ __ ] comic and the
acting just got in the way
yeah so you kind of like realized acting
yeah
and you saw he was in character like
starting fights he got a real tattoo and
it's like
oh yeah like bro i was like oh this
isn't for me i do not belong holding a
character the whole time like i'm on the
joke yeah
but then when we did find kid 3d which
was similar right that's because we're
hanging out we're writing
but couldn't you do that like you could
do if you're like a judap
or happy madison type of thing you could
do that right
yes if i was coming up with the funny
and we were all together remember we
were friends
doing this sit together and sitting
around making things is it because you
don't feel like you're
you were friends with any of those
people it's just that it there's so many
moving parts
and you it's such a slow pace and
process
i love that the slowest pace it's it's a
page
they shot one scene on that movie that
the terrible page a day
no it dude the one scene took all day
all day and i didn't need to be there
but i had to be there you got to be in
the background
you had a watch yeah oh yeah with a mask
with a mask
before kobe this guy was trying i kept
taking the mask out i need people to see
me that
caught [ __ ] hey negro
yeah that was his name that's what the
[ __ ]
yeah man did you watch the movie i did i
did i was
so mad that i did but i saw him yeah
yeah i watched i watched i can talk
about it now but like when i was on the
joker
joaquin phoenix won an oscar awesome but
you know the guy had to lose weight now
he did it they will get you a
nutritionist he's like no i'll just
smoke cigarettes and eat one apple a day
and for three months that's what he went
from 186 to 124.
and a lot of those guys they give him
bro i was there for five days with him
the guy
was in character the entire time he
didn't get out of character
and he was that guy i i you can you know
i can't do it you know who else is like
that uh jared leto have you seen that
have you seen his new look at that new
for gucci gucci
it looks so good you gotta see how he
looks if you're that good and you can do
that oh there i am there you are look at
you
there you go i mean i can't see any of
you
was the stunt man was there any other
stuff around
did they not have anybody is that the
mess you were trying to
by the take how long how long was that
scene i mean up to a half a day okay get
up there
just shoot between uh wow look at you
look at you that's a great time that's a
great shot where are you
where there's no you're not there either
yeah and he was very uh
he was very serious huh yes the most
serious
he went around shooting straight on to
get into character he looks like he's
got a little he went around what
that's fake he went around in l.a
shooting stray dogs to help him get into
character
she didn't know he believed it yes he
did no he didn't know that's what he
said
yeah you know he did yeah his girl came
and said that that
uh twigs or whatever [ __ ] her name
shooting straight off trying to get into
the role for this
wow gosh some of these [ __ ] go
go far
that's what happened with the one guy
the joker he's ledger huh
right no no no because he played with no
heath ledger was just a really good
actor who came up with a really
cool interesting way to move
and talk and that's acting like he's
copying that but he i forget who he
copied the manner
no no some singer he can't be too uh
keith richards you mean no no no no yeah
i was a singer
oh so he wasn't like no but i mean he
learned the exact manner
yeah but he was big and like and he was
very talented that's that's a different
thing when you're getting
this in the character yeah
i mean and i feel like the rock does it
right this [ __ ] looks fun he's like
jumping out of planes and [ __ ]
you don't have to be like play a
character he's just himself or liam
neeson like who's like you know
i'll make a lot of money do a little bit
of do a little bit of acting yeah
yeah do a little bit of that rest of his
action yeah and the way jared
leto looked in that one movie dallas
spider's club no the uh
oscar for that the this is the one with
denzel the one i didn't really like it
first with denzel rami malik
oh the little thing and the way he
looked in that movie
but have you seen that have you seen how
they how what it's like to shoot an
action movie when you run downstairs and
stop
the gun out and it's just piecemeal man
it's difficult he's a special dude huh
yeah that's your boyfriend that's your
spirit animal right yeah i wish i was
him
he gets into his character took me on a
tour in north hollywood to all the spots
that they recorded in because he used to
live in that area
the little things yeah does he drink
blood of
of of children he doesn't get old no
genetics are insane i mean he just stays
48
he's 48 yep no yeah jared little yeah
yeah
look he's really really good yeah
he can sing too man yeah there's a with
30 seconds to mars yeah i love him
yeah and he wears he's such a fashion
king yeah he was the face of
uh gucci forever 49. he's 49.
hey pull up that picture of his new role
is he what's his what's his nationality
new role happening
he's a child actor look at his he's one
that came up in
acting yeah look at him insane it's
crazy
that's him that's jared leto where no
yeah hold on wow
that's incredible and i bet he kills
that role too that's incredible
he was also in a rec room for a dream
that uh
that drug movie where everybody was like
on heroin and [ __ ]
i mean that's that's unbelievable right
there yeah
he's a great actor jesus can't wait
oh yeah he all about the fashion i'd
rock that out it's so [ __ ] fire
i'd rock that [ __ ] not many people
i don't know if i could pull it off you
want to be that guy imagine if i showed
up what do they call that boat neck
right you that's it you want that so
badly you just don't have to
build it couldn't be further from yeah
and all i want to be is i want to be
built like i i play football and i don't
have that either
we all want something we're not yeah
there he looks more like me there we go
now he's more of my build all right jim
what do you got for us
wow wait isn't there some video if you
want that suit
or something like that and you have like
uh when we did uh uh
we did a family skit oh
so um this is a very similar situation
to the liam neeson
one where he did an interview saying
that he was hunting down black men after
finding out that his
uh friend was raped and nobody asked him
for he just kind of offered it up
matt damon did a similar thing while he
was doing a press junket that's why
these guys don't want to do prayers and
podcasts everybody pieces it out
he was on mare and he's great and what
he ended up saying was that he
jokes with his family and every now and
then he'll use the eff slur
and his daughter a few months ago said
hey don't say that that's the reason why
you shouldn't say that
and he said oh cool i'll retire this
because at first he said
it should it'd be fine in his household
to say if it was a joke
and now because his daughter convinced
him otherwise he doesn't use the word
anymore even as a joke
but nobody asked him for the story he
just and now he's getting a bunch of
backlash
he's getting a lot of backlash he said
he he was saying as a joke because he
says in a movie
yeah uh that stuck on you movie
exactly and his daughter was still yeah
and his daughter still said like hey
don't use that and he's saying that he
understands why he's getting some
backlash from it but people just are
confused on why he
chose to say the story because nobody
asked him about it just like
they think he should have just kept it
to himself yeah absolutely because i
think it's good that he's admitting like
oh
i am learning as a person what i should
and shouldn't say
what like offends other people but i
just don't know
in the interview with man oh really yeah
it's funny my 13 year old
uh reads fantasy novels and yeah a lot
of the fantasy novels now have
a lot of queer uh characters oh so she
went down the rabbit hole on youtube
about queer culture and trans culture
and all that
so what happens when you're 13 is that
you take your dad to task about all
things trans and all things lgbtq and
all apparently she's not learning enough
in school about
it and then daddy starts pushing back a
little bit because i'm old school guy
and i go well it's not
we'd let's learn our reading writing
arithmetic first and maybe some history
as well and then we can get into that
later
but i was i was the same thing i'm
having arguments about all that and
you know it just your kids you know they
change you
i don't have kids yeah you'll see you'll
see
because they're with the times and
you're a dinosaur and they look at you
like you're a [ __ ] dinosaur oh really
yeah damn yeah it's always been that way
though it's all good
it's all good what else you got to do uh
yeah we were talking about this earlier
the baby was pulled out of
headlining day four of lollapalooza i
think he recently
got pulled out of another music festival
uh one in vegas right so if he
apologized would he be able to go back
in he didn't want his apology not
allowed anymore
but he doubled down on it i think there
was a time and place where he could have
apologized and it could have been fine
but he chose to double down instead
yeah i respect it really just about
sometimes you gotta double down
yeah oh yeah because he came up with
like a video
yeah he came out with the music video
right after doubling down on it
no like he came out like a video of him
talking about it yeah
he did a few things but uh word got to
elton john about this and he
i guess made a few phone calls that
ultimately got him pulled yeah
and john goes hey get this get out of
here you're going to listen to and even
quest love came out
and uh said that he doesn't support the
baby and what he was saying
the baby then came out and said that he
didn't know who quest love was which a
bunch of people lit him up for because
he's
like such a huge plus loves like a
legendary
in hip yeah and the rap community so
people are now going out to baby
sounds like he has the same pr agent as
conor mcgregor
people are giving him [ __ ] because
they're saying if chris brown has to
come out and give you pr advice you're
definitely in the room even chris brown
chris brown came out on instagram and he
said get on stage perform thank the
audience and get the [ __ ] out
shut the [ __ ] up yeah he's basically
saying that and then he deleted it he
took it down
but if chris brown is giving you pr
advice
you better chill the [ __ ] out yeah yeah
how powerful is elton john if an hour
before yeah on stage goes hey i don't
want him on stage like
yeah man yeah he has a residency in
vegas
and john yeah yeah oh you the scarlet
johansson so she's going to suit
yeah scarlett johnson is currently in a
lawsuit with disney
not necessarily marvel but with disney
because they had a contract saying that
she was getting paid a certain
amount for doing the film and then she
gets a percentage of
what the film makes as during the
theatrical release
but disney recently because of covid has
been releasing things
on disney the streaming app as well but
you have to buy it
from the streaming app so it's not
necessarily for free you still have to
buy it but you can watch it from the
comfort
of your home rather than being in
theaters which then significantly
affected the amount of money she was
able to make from the theatrical it
seems like we're trying to adapt to the
times we can't predict covet but they're
saying that i
breached her contract yeah because the
deal they penned was that
she gets a piece and she stood to make
about 50 million also be careful there's
a bee in the studio
so she so she's going to assume she's
currently suing disney because they were
the ones who put it out onto their
streaming platform not marvel
and even marvel is disappointed with
disney putting it out on
a streaming platform on the same weekend
as its theatrical release
they were hoping it would come out later
yeah disney owns marvel right
yes she'll she might win this yeah and
it's not going to go to trial what they
do is they just come to settle
kind of kind of set out of court ever
again though
this was her last film technically there
you go so she was contracting
on marvel yeah because her character
spoiler alert for anybody who hasn't
seen it
her character dies what what what
widows my friend my friend went so bad
on it he's like she doesn't even have
any magical powers
she can just like little kid just kicked
that's all she can do yeah she ain't
just kidding
she's an assassin she's the worst oh
okay all right
i guess is there a comic book about
black widow oh yeah she's a character in
it i don't know if she has like her
own standalone comic as of now they're
only
yeah i don't care she doesn't have like
like power superpowers and she's just
not anywhere yeah she's a guy when i saw
her in disney i'm like that can't end
well i mean she'll get money but but
they sit in the cut like
oh disney people
have fun at disneyland next week yeah
yeah
oh my god casa bonita so what is casa
bonita is a restaurant in denver
and like if you grew up in denver it's
like you went to
the worst food in the world but you had
to buy food in order to get to the
theme park yeah it was the indoor
mexican theme park
and they had yeah it was great and they
had cliff divers grow
like well they would they would dive
into the water
yeah and they had uh uh like jumping uh
what do you call them like the jumping
beans
like the jumpings that do all this [ __ ]
yeah there wasn't much to it but it was
when i say this it was the worst food in
the world
but you had to sit there and eat i
remember we got kicked out because my
mom refused to eat the food
but you have to eat the food you have oh
[ __ ] they go
theme park so you have to get through
the restaurant and get the theme park
my mom's like i don't want this [ __ ]
like and you ain't getting in yeah
i was like then we ain't getting in i
was like mama please dear god just eat a
[ __ ] enchilada
so anyone who grew up in denver i don't
know this place it's a [ __ ] show but
it recently became a landmark for you
guys oh really yeah
yeah that's amazing if you have kids
they they everybody goes there
did you have fun when you were a kid
though yeah yeah i loved it do they have
any money that south park
guys yeah well they were trying to buy
it right yeah because casa bonita is
currently
uh bankrupt and they're looking to sell
it but for some reason the owners of
the theme park came out and said that
they're not going to sell it to
the south park creators the south park
creators want to buy it redo it
with like a better version but they are
refusing to sell to them oh man south
park's in its 23rd season
they are so amazing a bunch of people
from colorado really wanted them to be
able to buy it but i saw them i mean
that'd be good but the owners are saying
no they buy it it'll be it'll probably
be the greatest place ever oh this place
was so sick i mean even with the shitty
resource they had
but you had to eat the food dude you
were
[Applause]
i love in-n-out burgers right uh-huh and
i bought i bought
yeah how about this i buy one i ate it
when it was hot delicious
i left in my car and i was after my show
it was night and i was like
let me get a bite of this cold hamburger
0-100 well dude that
lard coats your mouth and i was like oh
this is disgusting in and out is only
good for its price point it's not like
the best burger in the world
i don't think that's five bucks this is
better is it johnny rockets
yeah i don't know it's at the next round
johnny i can't remember that so i had a
are you are you are you marty mcfly yeah
those places are fire come on
you're rocking my major chains here
first of all i'm mad at your shirt dog
huh horny you're mad at it it's just as
horny yeah
do you not like girls my friend made it
to
for me so i told him i'd wear it for him
you know he's going to sell his shirts
sure that company companies do great
the company's killing it
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah that's a yeah that's a young man's
shirt yeah horny
period it's a way to let him know what i
think i even want him
[Laughter]
what the [ __ ] horny
you guys are just talking about simone
biles she's going to be coming back
really yeah she's turning to that
shouldn't have
she's doing that thing that pedestal
thing or whatever oh my horse pump no no
balance she will be in the olympics yes
she's going to be you know what's
interesting though
the girl that took over for her not
replaced with the one that
so she was the captain she's out next
girl who
i think she she's born in america but
she's south asian
she's mom yeah she's pretty too how old
is she she
i don't know i think she's over 18.
she's pretty though very pretty
she's crushing it
uh was it the floor exercise or the uh
uh you know
gymnastics i see i love gymnastics
you're not that into it
if it went away i wouldn't give a flying
really no that's why i
i don't have
i don't care about any of it okay no
what's your you don't care about
anything not any of this
how about track and field fastest man in
the world oh you know what's it you know
what's interesting about no don't care
but you know what's interesting
is uh so you know the the the the girl
who
uh smoked weed yeah
let me let me tell you this chin i mean
uh brian let me tell you this yeah it's
the lids if you took her
fastest time listen to this all the
uproar of all that stuff
if you took her fastest time that she's
ever ran
she wouldn't have finished in the top
three she would have got
fourth or fifth she wouldn't she didn't
have a prayer in getting gold i'm sorry
which one were you talking about in the
girl who smoked weed
and she got sponsored by beats by dre
and people are like this is so wrong all
she smoked weed right then
then the rules yeah the jamaicans are so
she wasn't the fastest i thought she was
i think she was fast in america did not
know this here
not even here so hopefully she wouldn't
she wouldn't have meddled
in any facet i thought the jamaicans
went one two and three oh yeah
and then the jamaican who had number one
yeah she could ran backwards shikari
richardson that's
yeah i forgot oh i did not know in the
100 meters yeah remember how big of an
uproar this was well
she wouldn't have finished in the top
four i did not know that
i didn't you took her if you took her
best time ever she would
and then she was like oh i bet you all
missing me now no
the jamaicans are like what yeah
jamaicans are all you don't think we
want to smoke weed [ __ ]
shut the [ __ ] up one pretty girl
one two and three one one two and three
sorry yeah and they've won
it's their national pass eleven years
please understand it's only an island of
seven million people or so
and jamaica yeah and they dominate the
world
to dominate track yeah yeah in the
fastest people in the world in
jamaica i thought that was so
interesting yeah how many gold members
all that hype god damn it i fell for it
i thought she had a chance
i was like oh we would have got gold oh
she just smoked weed and the jamaicans
would excuse me which is no
well no all three you were in the
competition jamaicans went do they give
a medal for fourth or fifth place
oh they don't then yeah now what would
it get what would um the jamaican women
there's a very good question how are
they doing this hold on hold please they
wouldn't
no they wouldn't even qualify no you
know i know that i'm aware of that
but i wanted to ask you what do you
think and i'm going to give you a number
and i want you to tell me if i'm right
the one two and three fastest jamaican
women
would run a 40 in four
four four maybe four four no not even
close no
no no four you think four eight look
that up please chin
i don't know how would that you can
actually they they do it that you can
see it because
you said both when they ran the 42 or
something crazy
um no he first of all hussein boat ran
up 4-1
without even warming up is that true
yeah at the nfl combat
is that true yeah he went to the nfl
thing around in 4-1 without
his technique and starts and stuff like
that so imagine he was in like he was
like regular shoes yeah he was like yeah
he's like in sweat i got to see that
uh yeah it's just 100 meters
okay so oh
and then what what was that what was
chicago the fastest man
in america is a white boy out of georgia
is that true yep huh
wow i'm gonna say i'm gonna say no to
that
he's tyson gay he's black
isn't he tyson gabriel see tyson gay
tyson you get younger he he hasn't been
relevant
in a hot second uh he's right there
lamar
marcel jacobs takes over the fastest man
in the world oh he won
what were you saying was not running i i
haven't watched one
one thing of this no you're saying
retired
oh yeah i'm sorry i don't think how
phelps do this year i don't follow
tracker what's someone dominating dogs
i'm asking a question about who's saint
paul oh there he
i don't is and he won the italian
oh [ __ ] italian yeah
there you go he didn't look for you 100
meter
yeah yeah
okay what was the fastest women's uh
time
why are you doing this i mean it's not
you're horny
that's why he's doing it he's horny what
else you got jen a horny man there
um this right here so after this year in
tokyo
the ioc will re-look at you know
transgender
people in in sports really it's just
bodybuilding right that's what they're
doing well yeah this is gender competing
power lifting oh did they have power
they competed she lost
she actually didn't meddle yeah she
actually hit that snatcher and she's
like oh my god i didn't mean to laugh
no wow that's strange times getting
straight she lost too yeah so then after
this
it's a big one here so what are they
going to do
um they're going to change the rules the
rules right now it still gives an
advantage to transgender people as you
can imagine right although they didn't
win though so
no no no but she didn't plays
yeah it's interesting that the
testosterone really rules are too
lenient so they're gonna be changing
so they're gonna make it harder yeah
they're gonna make changes makes sense
wait harder for transgender to to
compete yeah yeah
they have to suppress their testosterone
below 10 nanomoles per liter for at
least 12 months prior
their first competition problem is when
they when the transgender is like if
it's a male to female and they get into
wrestling that's where it gets a little
dicey
even weightlifting too man that's like
come on do you know that
before all of this that almost all
transgender cases were male to female
almost all it was almost never female to
male
and until as far as going into sports
just
now just just the the female gender what
they call it
isn't really an issue because they're
not gonna yeah they're not gonna do well
enough but the case
the the the so so typically according to
what i have read
the cases of transgender like the cases
before
say i don't know 20 15 before all this
became such a craze
um were primarily male to female
and a lot of children boys who identify
as female when they're younger
a lot of times by the time they're 18
whatever it is or
16 become gay become gay men you know so
it's not that they are they're they're
just
going through something when they're
kids so that's why it's one of the
arguments against
puberty blockers at an a younger age
before you're ready to make your own
decisions
yeah again i wanted robot arms remember
that that's right
dad will let me do it you'll get him
all right this happened at lollapalooza
uh guy thrown out of a window yeah so
apparently the witnesses are saying they
had some argument about the wristbands
but this is crazy they have a video yeah
it's
kind of choppy but you'll see was that
someone threw this guy out that window
and you can tell he's jacked up
is that him god
[Music]
see if i was really big and strong i
think i would do that it'd be fun to
throw something why did he throw him out
of the window
some argument about wristbands maybe
he's trying to sell him something who's
the guy
is the guy limping the one who got going
out yeah and the guy that walked
gotta walk out as we got through him
most likely damn do you break his leg
no but i'm sure he got gashed up you
know yeah yeah poor
gaster he got scared and just got
decided to scoot away on it
he's
that's the bear man wow that's him
trying to win a lawsuit though
i mean that's not look at that look yeah
there's somebody
was there yes but also like get up
yeah but also yeah get up on with brian
it's not how to protect yourself that's
bad self-defense
unless you're in jiu jitsu i guess and
you're crabbing up
i saw sam tripoli post this oh i saw
this one this morning
hey twitter world let's meet yours too
with the world real interesting today
you know with 99 of whatever percent of
people dying or the unvaccinated from
from the new covet stuff and over 90
of hospitalizations especially in
florida are among the unvaccinated
a female doctor was on this morning she
made the best analogy
she said that being vaccinated is like
wearing your seat belt
that it doesn't guarantee you won't get
in an
accident but if you do you have a much
better chance of surviving
hey get your shots i don't like wearing
masks and as you people
who aren't getting the shots that has
brought this mass thing back
i'm just saying take care has the guys
been through
everything well look at that comment he
gave nicole and ron that jab years ago
people are [ __ ] insane
what the [ __ ] well
oj doing his best man hanging in there
you know
it's just the way he talks is so
hilarious wait did you say he gives
money monthly for like the nfl or
something like that
yeah it gets a pension convention yeah
300 grand a year
oh yeah and i don't think the browns can
take any of that
that's one thing they can't touch i
don't think so no that's how he's
playing golf and [ __ ]
i wonder if he does out at clubs and
[ __ ]
money from nfl
300 yep yeah
yeah and then uh
clicking that uh did the goldmans get
any money they did
they because they're civil right
yep looks pretty good for 74. yeah
this is just a picture of jonah hill oh
he looks healthy
but he's 37 wait 37 [ __ ] cameras in
the way
oh sorry that's amazing can you see it
there
yeah he's i think he's a great actor
he's phenomenal
he's always struggling with his weight
a lot of tats there's a spin on body
glove he calls it body love
i think the most fascinating thing about
this is we are looking at him and he's
only 37.
it's a trip yeah yeah his face
well i think when you lose and gain
weight that rapidly that too that's yeah
your face
your face oh okay is he back to skinny
now
this is him right now yeah i don't like
dude he could be
seven hold on his face yeah it looks
like he's probably
thinner now yeah his hair looks long i
met him once he's so [ __ ] oh he looks
good right there
i think that's just a weird angle he's a
nice guy and he's a talented guy
he's very funny he is he's really
[ __ ] good you follow him kyle
yeah like i think he's a phenomenal
actor actually i think he's what he does
is really good yeah
dude him and that leonardo dicaprio
movie yeah he's great yeah
he's great in the django too yep good
for him man he's getting healthier
mm-hmm always wore it it's not easy he's
working hard no tatted up now
good for him selfish because i liked it
when he's fat i thought he's fine
yeah but he wanted to be healthy you
know oh look at this
yeah so jean-claude jean-claude van
damme has a movie on netflix right now
it's like the top three
damn oh young too
let's get let's focus let's bring it
back to oh he has the same here as brian
you guys have the exact same here yeah
listen you're the exact same here it's
terrible to see what age does
god damn it he's in his 70s right i
think he turns
60. oh he turns 60.
still a stud man he's not yeah i thought
he was older
i thought he was older [ __ ] i thought so
too
yeah he's not 5 10. i literally was like
he's in the 70s
right 5 10 it's not true yeah that's not
true steven seagal is 70.
all right steven seagal's agent like an
avocado 81
yeah i met chuck norris he was a nice
guy chuck norris a legend he gave me an
order he gave me an autographed
[ __ ] picture [ __ ] right did he ask
for he just gave no he just gave it to
me
but i was excited anyway
i had it for the longest time i lost
chuck norris is 80. yeah legit he got he
got a fight not too long ago someone
tried to mug him
like a couple of years ago walker texas
yeah someone tried to mug him or
something like that chuck norris
street fighter just talking like mug or
no talk about
your mug yeah chuck norris mugged
like that two criminals tried to rob
no no all right maybe it was one of
those
chuck norris uh yeah probably
we got one of those [ __ ]
chocolate pushed the earth down we did
push
chuck norris versus sage northcutt all
right please don't oh there was
something it was like chuck norris
okay it was like some chuck norris was
uh born on the day to nazis surrender or
something
dude they're great so stupid do you see
that movie
the guy richie movie the gentleman no i
saw a little piece of it it's good
guy richie don't make a bad movie yeah
that's a good like colin farrell
in that is so charlie
he sounds exactly like conor mcgregor
same exact part of ireland
oh i need to check this yeah all great
actors dude yeah
yeah jason theater says great yeah i
mean guy ritchie doesn't matter and
and colin farrell is so good in it he
plays this boxing trainer oh we need
those man
yeah we were gonna wear those yeah for a
certain city because
we were gonna wear them that could be
david on the right
yeah he's good right look at him yeah
we gotta get is that it that's it
that's it all right kids that's it
uh second fight calabash fight command
this saturday ufc 265 with the squad
normal crew special guest tj dillashaw
coming off the surgery on his leg he's
still showing up
to bring painkillers uh north carolina
august 19th
through august 21st then la jolla comedy
store
we are not doing sunday anymore because
we have a fight campaign that sunday for
jake paul versus woodley so that sunday
got switched to thursday so now be two
shows thursday
two shows friday two shows saturday at
la jolla comedy store in california
august 26 through the 28th now
then san jose is september 9th through
the 11th
the big boy santo texas bud light event
center
one night uh one show september 24th one
show september 25th
get your tickets at f a tkz.com or
i'll be at i'll be in san diego the
first show's already sold out
uh american comic club we might add a
second show now so get your tickets
i know i'm actually coming do two shows
right exactly
so get your tickets for the second show
houston improv texas i'll be
in at the improv august 19 20 21 buffalo
new york helium
september 9 through 11. done that before
great club yeah
denver colorado comedy works september
23rd 24th 25th
improv in chicago oh yeah it was the
oh schomburg oh no that's not your
channel i'll be there september 30th to
october 1st get your tickets mama i'm
coming home uh
august 26th i'll be at brea improv one
night only
october 7th through the 9th i'll be in
tampa florida at side splitters
october 28th through the 30th uh
washington dc to dc comedy loft
and then going back to tacoma later at
the end of
the year november 17th and then spokane
that next day november 18th
get all the tickets f-a-t-k-z for the
boys
companion this saturday we're out love
you guys